therapists and their patients are
dealing with a nationwide shortage of
Adderall one of the best known
treatments for ADHD according to
National Data Adderall prescriptions for
adults jumped 15 percent from 2020 to
2021. some extrovers blame the shortage
on the explosion of online mental health
providers that diagnose cases and
prescribe a lot of medication one of
those online platforms cerebral has been
the focus of an ongoing CBS News
investigation and earlier this year it
was a subject of a justice department
probe our consumer investigative
correspondent Anna Werner is here with
the latest good morning Anna how you
doing good morning Nate doing very well
you know after our last story we heard
from a mother in the state of Washington
who wanted us to look into the story of
what happened to her son after he went
to cerebral seeking Adderall and
questions as to whether online mental
health care really delivers on its
promises
I learned the reasons behind habits I've
had my whole life if you spent any time
on Tick Tock over the pandemic you
probably came across ads like these I
had no idea this was caused by
undiagnosed ADHD mental health companies
offering fast affordable treatment for
ADHD attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder completely online one of the
biggest companies is called cerebral
cerebral provides a discrete
judgment-free way to be screened for
ADHD often that treatment came with a
prescription for a frequently used
medication Adderall a controlled
substance tightly regulated by the drug
enforcement administration because it
carries a high potential for abuse
Adderall is an amphetamine it's a highly
addictive drug Dr Andrew colodny is a
prescribing expert these are dangerous
drugs that are controlled for a good
reason prior to the pandemic a law
called the Ryan hate act required
medical professionals to see patients in
person before prescribing any control
substance but the law was temporarily
lifted due to the pandemic meaning those
drugs can now be prescribed through
online appointments and online companies
including cerebral have urged the
government to drop that in-person visit
requirement permanently something Dr
kolodny sees as risky without the
requirement for a face-to-face visit you
can see businesses take advantage of the
ease in which these drugs can be
prescribed the potential for abuse is
just too high if it's just online that's
correct I come here daily Kelly
Rasmussen of Tacoma Washington says
she's seen that firsthand her 21 year
old son Elijah Hansen was prescribed
Adderall by cerebral when did you first
find out that he had gone to cerebral I
did not even know he went to cerebral
until after I found a pill bottle Elijah
had struggled with mental health issues
for years for which he was taking
prescription medication but his younger
brother Ethan says in the past he and
Elijah had also abused Adderall and this
year Ethan says Elijah told him he'd
found a way of getting more Adderall
through cerebral he lied and said he had
ADHD even though medical records show
Elijah had never previously been
diagnosed with ADHD cerebral records
show he claimed to one of their
prescribers in February that he wanted
help for that disorder that prescriber
declined to give him a stimulant deeming
him a risk to prescribe a controlled
substance so he tried again in April
this time a different cerebral
prescriber gave him the Adderall your
brother said that he lied right and told
them that he had something else adhdhd
yeah and to get that get the Adderall
right in an interview this June cerebral
CEO Dr David Moe defended the company's
prescribing practices we had really
really good clinical outcomes when it
comes to depression and anxiety and PTSD
and ADHD and even serious mental
illnesses such as bipolar
but in this letter last month obtained
by CBS News predecessor cerebral founder
Kyle Robertson removed by cerebral's
board earlier this year claims some of
the company's leading investors pushed
for increased prescriptions for drugs
like Adderall he says one board member
told him the easier you make it for
people to get stimulants the better for
the business and its customers the
company told us Robertson's allegations
are categorically untrue
as for Elijah Hansen records show his
family doctor continued his Adderall
prescription relying on the ADHD
diagnosis made by cerebral you can
definitely tell he was taking way too
much and he wasn't in his right mind at
all on June 25th his mother returned
home from an errand to an inconceivable
sight Elijah lying dead on the kitchen
floor he'd found a gun kept in the house
and recorded himself playing Russian
roulette I came home and
he was gone
I can't imagine what that was like
every day is a struggle I'm angry that
this online platform just thinks that
handing out these medications to people
is okay
because it's not
now if you or someone you know is
seeking Mental Health Resources you can
call the National Alliance on Mental
Illness helpline at
1-800-950-6264 or in a crisis text
helpline to
62640 now cerebral told us it cannot
comment on specific case patients cases
in a statement it told us it has robust
systems to detect and intervene when it
suspects drug-seeking Behavior the
company also says it has since stopped
prescribing controlled substances and to
date has not been accused by Regulators
of any wrongdoing or violation of law
yeah I'll bet that mother would beg to
differ I'm with you and I can't imagine
what that was like it's bad enough to
find your son dead but then to know that
he recorded it too why does she believe
that outer role played a role here he
and she and the brother and the family
members were telling me that it was
clear that he was taking taking too much
that he was losing weight he was getting
very skinny lost like 20lbs and his
behavior changed he was isolating
himself and um and they also think that
he might have been seeking a thrill it's
not clear whether he meant to uh to die
by Suicide they think that he may have
been you know sort of amped up looking
forward and looking for a rush and this
is why he engaged you know videotaped
himself in in a very very very risky
Behavior so a lot of questions there in
terms of the death and I don't think
she's ever going to know the answers
which is hard uh and another great
investigation very powerful stuff